distinguish between you as the designer
of your machine and you as a worker
within your machine one of the hardest
things for people to do is to
objectively look down on themselves
within their circumstances in other
words within their machine so that they
can act as the machines designer and
manager most people remain stuck in the
perspective of being a worker within
their machine if you can recognize the
differences between those roles and that
it is much more important that you are a
good designer manager of your life then
a good worker in it you will be on the
right path
to be successful the designer manager
you has to be objective about what the
worker you is really like not believing
in him more than he deserves
or putting him in jobs that he shouldn't
be in instead of having this perspective
most people operate emotionally and in
the moment their lives are a series of
undirected emotional experiences going
from one thing to the next if you want
to look back on your life and feel
you've achieved what you wanted to you
can't operate that way d the biggest
mistake most people make is to not see
themselves and others objectively which
leads them to bump into their own and
others weaknesses again and again people
who do this fail because they are
stubbornly stuck in their own heads if
they could just get around this they
could live up to their potential this is
why higher-level thinking is essential
for success e successful people are
those who can go above themselves to see
things objectively and manage those
things to shape change they can take in
the perspectives of others instead of
being trapped in their own heads with
their own biases they are able to look
objectively of what they are like their
strengths and their weaknesses and what
others are like
put the right people in the right roles
to achieve their goals once you
understand how to do this you'll see
that there's virtually nothing you can't
accomplish you will just have to learn
how to face your realities and use the
full range of resources at your disposal
for example if you as the designer
manager of your life discovers that you
as the worker can't do something well
you need to fire yourself as the worker
and get a good replacement while staying
in the role of the designer manager of
your own life you shouldn't feel upset
at yourself if you find out that you're
bad at something you should be happy you
found out because knowing that and
dealing with it will improve your
chances of getting what you want if
you're disappointed because you can't be
the best person to do everything for
yourself you're terribly naive nobody
can do everything well would you want to
have I'm Stein on your basketball team
when he fails to dribble and shoot well
would you think badly of him should he
feel humiliated
imagine all the areas in which Einstein
was incompetent and imagine how hard he
struggled to excel even in the areas in
which he was the best in the world
watching people struggle and having
others watch you struggle can I listen
to all kinds of ego driven emotions such
as sympathy pity embarrassment anger or
defensiveness you need to get over all
that and stop seeing struggling as
something negative most of life's
greatest opportunities come out of
moments of struggle it's up to you to
make the most of these tests of your
creativity and character asking others
who are strong in areas where you are
weak to help you is a great skill that
you should develop no matter what and it
will help you develop guardrails that
will prevent you for doing what you
shouldn't be doing all successful people
are good at this G because it is
difficult to see oneself objectively
you need to rely
the input of others and the whole body
of evidence I know that my own life has
been full of mistakes and lots of great
feedback it was only by looking down on
this body of evidence from a higher
level that I was able to get around my
mistakes and go after what I wanted for
as long as I've been practicing this I
still know I can't see myself
objectively which is why I continue to
rely as much on others input H if you
are open-minded enough and determined
you can get virtually anything you want
so I don't want to dissuade you from
going after what you want at the same
time I urge you to reflect on whether
what you were going after is consistent
with your nature whatever your nature is
there are many paths that will suit you
so don't fixate on just one should a
particular path close all you have to do
is find another one consistent with what
you're like you'll learn a lot about how
to determine what you're like in the
chapter understand that people are wired
differently which comes later but most
people lack the courage to confront
their own weaknesses and make the hard
choices that this process requires
ultimately it comes down to these five
decisions first don't confuse what you
wish were true with what is really true
second don't worry about looking good
worry instead about achieving your goals
third don't overweight first-order
consequences relative to second and
third order ones fourth don't let pain
stand in the way of your progress and
fifth don't blame bad outcomes on anyone
but yourself